hey everyone my name is ashan and i
welcome you all to this session in this
video we will have a look at some devops
real-time scenarios
devops has helped businesses of all
types whether startups or fortune 500
companies all of them have started
moving towards devops as all of them are
interested in improving the speed and
quality of software development and to
name a few organizations we have nasa
amazon netflix walmart and facebook
devops have helped these companies in
fixing several issues and overcoming
several challenges here in this video we
shall have a look at some real time
problems that devops helped in solving
let's have a look at all the topics we
will be covering today
first we shall learn the basics of
devops
then we shall have a look at some
advantages of devops followed by some
real-time scenarios
in our main topic that is real-time
scenarios we shall have a look at four
significant parts
continuous integration scenarios
continuous testing scenarios
continuous delivery scenarios and devops
scenarios
so without any further ado let's get
started
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to click on the bell icon
so you never miss an update from
simplylaw now the first topic we have is
what is devops
devops is a software engineering culture
that unifies the development and
operations team under an umbrella of
tools to automate every stage
there are several phases in the devops
life cycle
beginning from the planning phase and
going up to the monitoring phase
the stages of devops begin with planning
and coding
in these phases tools like git and jira
software
are used to provide the repository for
managing and storing various code
versions
then comes the build phase
in this phase the tools like gradle and
maven are used to automatically fetch
the source code from the repositories
and package them into executable
applications
after the build phase comes the test
phase
testing in devops is automated within
the build pipeline to ensure that the
applications are deployable the most
common tool in this phase is selenium
next comes the deploy and operate phase
where tools like puppet and chef are
used to push the ready applications to
the deployment phase and continuously
configure them to the right state moving
forward comes the monitor phase where
the release products are continuously
monitored the most common tool used here
is negios devops stages will be
incomplete if we don't talk about the
integration phase the integration phase
is the heart of devops continuously
automating the integration of all the
different stages the most popular tool
that makes the process possible is
jenkins
now when we know the basics of devops
and the stages in devops let's have a
look at some benefits of devops benefits
of devops may be categorized under the
following categories
the first category is adaptability
devops makes it possible for
organizations to adapt better to market
trends and yield the maximum outputs
then another benefit of devops is fast
delivery
devops makes it possible to increase the
pace of releases bug fixing and response
to customers
the third category here is reliability
devops ensures the quality of
infrastructure and application updates
moving forward another critical category
is improved collaboration devops makes
it possible to have effective team
building that has core values like
ownership and accountability the last
category we shall see is security
automation increases consistency and
predictability that reduces human errors
now let's have a look at our main topic
that is real time scenarios
before diving deep into the subject
let's understand what does real-time
scenarios mean
real-time scenarios refer to the
problems issues or challenges that
happen in our daily lives
in this section
we shall have a look at the ways how we
can overcome such issues
we have divided the real-time scenarios
into four subsections
first being the continuous integration
scenarios second is the continuous
testing scenarios then third comes the
continuous delivery scenarios and
finally we have the devops scenarios
so let's begin with continuous
integration scenarios
the first scenario in the section is
continuous integration may decrease
productivity
the problem here is that the product is
made live as soon as the first working
model is created
the project managers pay most of their
attention to launching new features and
ensuring that deadlines are met there
may be conditions that developer has to
pause everything else and fix the bugs
first
now let's have a look at the key points
that could be done to solve this
there may be daily standups with all the
team members
then
project managers must understand all the
team members
it is really of great importance to have
a proper roadmap for developers and
lastly having continuous integration in
the entire process is of utmost
necessity the second scenario in the
continuous integration section is
adopting a new way of testing the
challenge here is that the development
process is slowed down when the project
is tested at each and every step
there have to be more tests which means
in order to write more test cases it
will take more time
then developers need to create the test
cases that can be used in the testing
process
now let's have a look at some key points
about what could be done to curb this
challenge
there must be a habit of writing test
cases from the beginning of the test
case
the team must know and understand that
development along with testing makes a
project robust
then the third and the last scenario in
this category is ignoring of error
messages
the challenge here is that developers
must not ignore error messages
these error messages must be read as
they provide hints to developers to
solve problems and challenges if such
messages are ignored they may result in
the wastage of money and resources now
let's have a look at some key points
that could be taken to face this real
time problem the first simple step is to
send only crucial messages
then the developers in charge should
only receive the relevant alerts
which means that it is not necessary for
all the developers to receive messages
for all the problems the developers must
receive messages for errors that
particularly concern them after the
continuous integration scenarios let's
have a look at the continuous testing
scenarios
if you are enjoying this video don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to our youtube channel so you never miss
an update from simply learn in this
section the first real-time scenario we
have is
right requirement specifications this
scenario talks about the teams spending
a lot of time and efforts on clarifying
the requirement specifications if a team
is able to set the right requirements
then almost half of the project is
already successful
so it is very important to a specific
and accurate understanding of
requirements which helps in designing
the test plans better the scenario for
this states that the teams must adopt
model based testing and behavior-driven
development techniques and the adoption
of such techniques will help generate
the right test cases from the initial
steps of each stage and help resolve the
gaps more quickly
then the second scenario here is making
of feedback loops the scenario concerns
the feedback loops at every stage if
there is no feedback at every stage of
the development cycle how will the
testing be possible
the process of continuous testing is not
possible without frequent feedback loops
at every stage of the development cycle
for the automation of the testing
process visibility of test execution and
results are of great importance
the next scenario in this continuous
testing scenarios is the management of
complexity it states that continuous
testing becomes more complex as it moves
towards the production environment
the number of tests grow along with the
complexity of the code
the tests are to be updated every time
the phases are updated
this increases the overall time to run
these tests
eventually delaying the release process
the solution of the problem is improved
test orchestration
it provides the right amount of test
coverage in shorter sprint cycles and
enables teams to deliver confidently
the fourth and the last scenario that we
shall see in the section is integration
of pipeline
the most important and the basic thing
needed for the implementation of
continuous testing is the automated
pipeline
to enable automation it is necessary to
integrate a pipeline then there is a
term called pipeline orchestration that
is based on understanding when to scale
how to analyze results how to scale why
it works and how it works
moving forward let's have a look at a
third subsection of real-time scenarios
that is the continuous delivery
scenarios the first scenario in the
section is slow deployments and no
standalone product at times the
complexity increases to such a level
where having uncertainty in terms of
what to deploy
where and how is a normal thing
the old development process was time
consuming which led to slower deployment
and delivery as well but now this is not
the case continuous development is
backed up by continuous integration
followed by continuous delivery
continuous integration with new features
make sure that a standalone product is
delivered at completion the second
scenario here is monitoring of the
product here the challenge is to know
what to monitor
as to know what to monitor is a
difficult task sometimes irrelevant data
is produced there may be times when the
amount of messages received as a result
of monitoring may be so much that it is
difficult to analyze by the developer or
sometimes they might be very less for
the developer to figure out the bugs
so to know how much to monitor may be a
challenge in itself
we must understand that monitoring the
product after delivery is an essential
process of development and then also the
process of bug fixing and product
maintenance requires the right amount of
monitor lock the third and the last
scenario in this continuous delivery
section is the missing of some
dependencies
there might be cases when a build is out
of date and some dependencies are
missing
these missing dependencies can lead to
the failure of the product this may be
costlier as maintenance is the most
significant part of the development life
cycle hence while deploying it is
important to make sure that the software
is well tested and packed
now when we have covered our three
subsections let's have a look at our
last section that is devops scenarios
the first scenario
is resolving problems devops promotes
transparency among different teams in an
organization
the entire devops scenario brings a
development team operations team and
security team together and makes them
collaborate with each other
efficiently and effectively successful
implementation of devops increases the
speed of tracing problems
in turn increasing the chances of
problems being fixed at an early stage
the second devops scenario is the
simplification of business process as
devops brings the teams closer and there
is a better definition to all the
segments of the project
this makes the process simplified by
reducing complex tasks into simpler
processes
therefore the time taken to complete the
process reduces extensively moving forth
the next real-time scenario is faster
release cycles
devops drive development teams in the
direction of continuous improvement and
faster release cycles
this is how devops promotes faster
release cycles along with continuous
improvement
this process in turn provides more time
to focus on some other factors that
really matter the reduced time plays an
important role in providing better user
experience here the last devops scenario
we shall see is deliver value to the
customers devops teams can focus on
business activities as the deployment
pipelines are automated the culture
reduces the time to deliver the value to
the customers
one of the biggest focuses of the team
is to create more customer value devops
activities increase the sustainable
competitive advantage of a company and
create better business outcomes
and so with this we have come to the end
of our real-time scenario session we
learnt about different real-time
scenarios on the basis of integration
testing delivery and in general devops
i hope you guys found it informative and
helpful
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here